Now here along the bottom
a digital signal is created via
a calculation performed
on the data being sent.
So it's unique to that message.
It can then be used for two purposes, to
validate that the message was unaltered
in transit, and that it actually
came from the purported sender.
Remember, the attachment was encrypted
using the recipient's public key.
The signature is encrypted
using the sender's private key.
The recipient's public key for
the message, sender's private key for
the signature.
Since anyone can obtain
the sender's public key,
anyone can decrypt the signature.
Here's where people get confused.
Keep two things in mind.
The digital signature
is not the message.
It is derived from the message.
So once decrypted, it can be used to
assure that the message can be trusted
and that it wasn't altered in transit.
The fact that it can be decrypted
using the sender's public key
ensures that it was encrypted by
the sender using their private key,
thus validating the source
of the message.
Nowhere was the sender's private key or
protected health
information compromised.
That's the essence of PKI for trust.
Most people who aren't already familiar
with PKI find this confusing, so
here are some questions to
make sure you're clear.